um
I just saw recently maybe two days ago
she had a spill Krishan had a spill
she's pregnant with your with your child
she had a spill at the club she fell out
um hey man I don't know I was just gonna
say that personally I don't think she
should be in the club this late in the
game I don't think she I thought she was
rolling up on Isley it's not about the
money it's not about now she just kind
of she just kind of lost in the
the hype of social media well I was
gonna say obviously you're she's
carrying your child that's your that's
your child right so how worried are you
about the safety of the womb the safety
of them I can't I can't worry until it's
it's on my plate you know right in her
belly when she has it I hope she watches
it wises up and like realize that every
penny is not worth